It's great to welcome to the program today,
Dr Sophie Leroy who is associate professor
at the University of Washington baffles school
of business.
A great to speak to you today.
I appreciate it.
Oh, you're welcome.
It's great to be on your show.
So let's just start with when we talk about
the idea of multitasking, does multitasking
even really exist or is it just switching
between one task and another and working on
each individually?
You're right.
Um, it actually does not fully exist.
Like I brain can not process two things at
the same time.
So what we do is actually we switched very
quickly between two things or even more.
Um, so we feel like we are multitasking when
in fact we are not, we're really, again, switching
back and forth, back and forth really, really
fast.
So when these, uh, tests or studies that are
sometimes done where someone is, for example,
driving a car on a closed course and they're
different obstacles that pop up and they're
simultaneously being given simple or sometimes
not so simple math problems over the phone.
It does seem as though you are both driving
and solving the math problems at the same
time.
But in some sense, are you sort of putting
the driving in an autopilot mode as you think
about the math problems?
Yes, absolutely.
And that's why from a performance standpoint,
this is really problematic, right?
Because what it means is that when you do
the math problem while you're driving, you're
actually not focused on the road.
You're not processing what's going on on the
road.
And so you can miss cues, you can miss things
that are happening.
Your reaction time is delayed, um, because
you need something else to capture your attention
very, you know, very fast back on the road.
Um, and so when you're not also when you're
on the road and not doing your math problem,
you're going to be slower at your math problem
because you're actually not processing the
math.
Right?
So from a performance standpoint, there are
many issues that come into play due to the
fact that because we're switching back and
forth there, it's very small time period where
you're actually not doing what you're suppose
to do.
So when we think about how we might sort of
do our work throughout the course of a day,
and there is a lot of this, what some people
might call multitasking, but it's really switching
between tasks back and forth.
Uh, there's the term attention residue, which
is an interesting term, which if I understand
correctly, relates to the way in which as
you switch between tasks, some of your attention
is not fully there yet or is remaining on
the prior task.
Is that more or less what we mean when we
say attention residue?
That's right.
And so it's a little different from the multitasking
aspect, right?
So multitasking, you're trying to do two things
at the same time and your brain is switching
back and forth, back and forth between those
two things.
Attention, residue is a little different in
the sense where it occurs when we work on
something and then we have to let it go and
transition to something else.
And in that case, our brain cannot do that
either.
We have a part time, um, transitioning because
we have a hard time letting go of things that
are incomplete.
So attention or is, it does not necessarily
occur all the time, but it occurs when we're
not fully satisfied with what we've done is
not finished.
We were interrupted in the middle of that
thought process and as we transition, the
brain does not want to let go, um, in part
because we have a need for completion.
And so those transitions or those interruptions
are really frustrating.
I need for, for full completion.
And so the brain is going to hold onto it,
process what's going on on that task that
we had to put aside.
And so what happens is we have actually divided
attention, our brain, in fact then multitask,
attention residue is a form of multitasking
and the dance that it will go back to the
task we were working on previously and, and
then at the same time tried to perform are
we supposed to do in the present?
Um, so it's a little different, right, in
terms of what triggers that.
Um, but it's very relevant to the workplace
as well because as you think about how we
work, right?
Oftentimes we have to go from meetings to
next we're working on a project balloon, there's
a phone call.
Um, if for example, about a call from a client
or someone else passing by a colleague who
needs some information and is asking some
questions, right?
So we have to transition very frequently and
Wooster transitions are just very, very hard,
um, for the brain to, to, to, to perform.
So when I interviewed cal Newport a few weeks
ago, who teaches computer science at Georgetown,
I believe it is, um, he suggests this idea
of planned deep work, right?
Focusing on single intense tasks for long
periods of time.
Because you're reducing the number of those
transitions that you're referring to and you
can be most sort of productive and thinking
most deeply when you spend a long period of
time focused on one thing.
Of course the practical issue seems to be
that in more and more jobs, 2030, 40, even
more than half of the job, it can basically
be writing emails and switching to meetings
and taking phone calls and those types of
activities.
So it seems like that is definitely the best
ideal, but it seems very impractical for many
modern jobs at this point in time.
Absolutely.
And, and that's actually where my, um, my
research is focused on is kind of assuming
that we can't change our corporate cultures,
um, that the neat can off this need, um, to
get information right away and can, if we
have a sense of urgency and that triggers
a lot of those interruptions.
Uh, think about all the technologies that
we have is fascinating.
All those interruptions.
And so if we assume that those interruptions
are going to stay, then how do we cope with
this, uh, cognitively?
Right?
So I'm going to go back to this side at that,
what is the brain in need for?
What prevents the brain to transition, to
move from one test to another, to move from
deep work to deep work?
Is this need for completion?
And so what I've found in my research is that
when we're in a position where we're all working
on something we are interrupted, isn't complete,
we ask to move, we need to spend maybe a minute
to create what I call them ready to resume
plan.
And so as I same idea of planning, it is a
different implementation of it, which is your
stop.
You say, okay, what is it that I was doing?
Where am I on my project?
What is it that I want to do next when I returned
to it?
So especially planning the return is critical
for the brain to feel like, okay, I can let
go because yes is not finished, but I have
a plan that will allow me to complete.
And so that sense of completion is not as
threatened as it is when we just drop everything
and switch [inaudible] we need to raise the
employee on.
What I've shown is that it actually helps
reduce attention residue on the next desk.
And as a result, performance on that net next
steps actually increased tremendously.
Um, I tested it for different ways, you know,
it improves the quality of our processing
in terms of processing or if information people
are able to pay more attention, it improves
the quality of a decision making that people
engage in.
Um, it improves, um, recall of information
so they have to recall information, think
that they've read.
Um, that's also has improved.
So what was really interesting is it was a
less than a minute intervention and that led
to huge impact on attention and on performance.
No.
What did you learn about?
So if you're, if you're writing something
for example, and you take a brief break to
look at your email and respond to one email
and then you go right back to the writing,
how long is the brain affected in terms of
limited focus after what might be just 30
seconds to write an email.
You know, it's, it's, it's actually is huge.
It's really surprising that how you, I think
it's counter intuitive for a lot of people.
How just this very brief interruption would
actually, um, um, affects you when you come
back.
Right?
So, so the issue of switching in that case
is you switch to something else than what,
what happens when you come back?
Well, the brain basically has to remember
where is it that you were and what kind of
thoughts, um, you can afford once your train
off.
That's where you were going and all levels
things by just switching away for a second,
then it's going to take you a long time to
remember where you were, to regain the, some
level of concentration to remember where you
were going.
Um, and so it doesn't really, I mean obviously
the longer the interruption, they're harder.
That switched back.
Um, you know, the harder it is to switch back.
But, but even small interruptions actually
a detrimental, and so I think that's where
like if you're writing something and you have
to switch, even if it was just a few seconds,
if you can have put capital ideas of what
you wanted to write, but even, you know, often
time people switched because it kind of like
they don't know what to do next.
They're not fully there or the bored or it's
gonna have a, a hurdle.
Right.
And so just write like, okay, I need to write
about X. I don't know how to, but that's okay.
And then you switch and then your return.
Oh yeah.
Now I know it was about next
that, that, that seems to me to be one of
the most pernicious elements of the sort of
modern task switching availability of social
media at anytime that you want.
Because at some point in the past, if you
are writing something and you have a very
brief, you know, momentary writer's block
for example, you think through it and maybe
in five minutes of your past it, but it's
so easy and it's so attractive to pick up
your phone and look at Facebook or look at
Twitter that even only 45 or 60 seconds later
you've now looked at, you know, 30 different
posts and thought about 30 different things.
It actually seems like it will hinder you
from getting past that writer's block in a
way that may be just sitting there quietly
for five minutes would actually let you work
through the problem.
Yes.
Because he makes you busy with something else
and you know, very some research that shows
that, um, when we let things incubate, um,
we get new ideas.
And so it's not that these is less about doing
something else, but if, if that next test
cause very pooling, very engaging and even
social media I up to some extent is you don't
have a cognitive space to actually answer
your friends while at the same time think
about the ideas that you were trying to express
that you know, or orbit problem you're trying,
you were trying to solve.
And so, um, we're not getting, we're not getting
matched by switching in that case from a pure
creativity standpoint or problems savings
standpoint.
Um, and so it, but it's tempting.
It's easier.
It feels good, right?
Yeah.
So I mean, I guess given that it's just our
phones and the apps and the Internet platforms
that we use are, are designed to keep our
attention for as long as possible.
How drastic do the measures need to be that
one uses or employees to avoid those temptations
and distractions?
I mean, should you be disconnecting your computer
from the Internet?
If it's possible.
What I mean it's just not practical.
Like when I'm preparing for my show, all of
my source material is on the Internet.
So I can't literally disconnect from the Internet,
but I can put my phone in the other room,
for example.
Yes.
Um, so maybe a couple thoughts, right?
I agree.
I think it's um, you know, but the more you
block what is tempting, you know, so he's
going to be different things for different
people.
Um, the, the, I think the easier it is to
not go there when you've faced with a challenge.
Um, one thing that I, for example do is, um,
I will look at the time and I said, okay,
for the next 30 minutes I am not touching
anything.
Right.
Um, now if there's something that I've, um,
that happened to me that I think is interesting
and also relevant to this kind of checking
out or checking Avu devices.
Um, for longest time I would put my phone
on vibrate so that I would not be interrupted.
But then I realized that, um, I would check
it because just in case this kid school cold
for example, just in case someone ugly texted
me and I felt like I need you to answer.
And I realized that was actually forcing me
to, to transition versus if I have it on volume,
um, then I don't have to worry about it because
I will hear it.
If someone wants to call me now, I have to
tell you, not a lot of people call me during
the day, so, right.
So that's also, I, I know that I can leave
that on volume and not be interrupted damage,
but he had completely removed all my checking
behaviors because I know if someone has to
reach me, I will hear them.
I don't have to worry about them.
And so I allow myself than to have my phone
with me.
Um, the other thing that I do is very much
like you, I do a lot of, in terms of research,
I have to be on the Internet and I will go,
I'm going to tell myself I am not going to
check the news.
I'm not going to take anything outside of
work.
Um, you know, even email for next two hours.
And, but that requires US discipline.
But the, the, the interesting part of it is
I think it's discipline that we can learn
and we can train our attention not to crave
for those, you know, fast gratification through
social media, for example.
Uh, we can train our brain to stick with what
we're doing for longer time periods, slowly.
Um, so that's where I think there's hope,
but it depends on what we are willing to do
and what our goals are.
Yeah, definitely.
It seems like there's an element in this in
which the brain is sort of like a muscle that
can be strengthened, so to speak, uh, to,
um, be better at maintaining attention for
longer, longer periods of time.
Uh, we have been speaking with Doctor Sophie
Leroy who is an associate yeah.
Professor at the University of Washington
Bothell school of business.
Thanks so much for talking to me today.
Oh, it was a pleasure.
Thank you so much for inviting me.